this is Startalk so tell me about this
the rest of what many people's
stereotype for autism such as like that
what used to be called idiot savant the
savant elements of autism artistically
it is are they are those people autistic
I think some of them are yeah absolutely
it and it is a big it's a big bucket a
big spectrum so you have people like
Temple who are who are doing great who
are doing great in society but then you
do have kids who haven't developed
language yet who really are impaired who
need a lot of help mm-hm
yeah but so but the people who have
these extraordinary so so temple has a
good hard-earned and well-deserved
reputation and contributions I'm talking
about the people that have singularly
odd like like the mental there's one
that comes to mind is a young man who
can play anything that he hears audibly
I don't care how complex the piece may
be he is able to replicate it right away
but not only replicate it he is able to
them in turn enhance it but he is
severely autistic we like that scene in
the movie Amadeus where he hears the
notes once and then plays it back yeah
it enhances it yeah I think you have
these musical geniuses temple I would
say she's certainly not an idiot she is
a savant aha things like that now I read
that Dustin Hoffman had interviewed
Temple Grandin to get some tips on how
to be Rain Man and so there is some you
know that's a good actor would do that
right it's what you do to try to get I
wouldn't know I'm an awful so can you
give us a the top three stereotypes that
people have for autistic people that you
want to oh yeah dispel I think number
one is that they don't care about other
people if you talk to people with autism
they'll tell you actually they do it's
just that it's really hard for them to
interact to be social and express it
exactly
number two is something we've been
talking about already that they'll never
amount to anything that they're
that they can't contribute to society
and that's false - and and we're hearing
about that firsthand from temple and and
we've learned that from a lot of other
people as well right those are really
the big two I think okay
that's right cool and so and she made
the interesting point in the in the
earlier clip that yes there are people
who will be collecting the the their
Social Security check or whatever but
the rest get about there absolutely and
but you can you do know how to draw that
line is that an awkward thing to do I
think the key is to start working with
the kids early and she was talking about
that too and then hopefully most of them
will be out there will be doing
something it's it's a tough hill to
climb and most people with autism now
adults living at home don't have regular
employment we need to work on at some
point you have to say that I can train
this person or I can't train this person
and that and that that line that you
draw might be different ten years from
now than it is today absolutely I think
as point you got to give everyone a
chance and and more awareness may lead
to that line being pushed back because
as people become more aware more
educated about autism then when we spot
it when I bought it you're you're able
to say oh I know what to do with this
person now or how to approach helping
this person sort of succeed this is
Startalk